the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones in
house of the dragon video in this video
i will be showing every single dragon
that was alive during the dance of the
dragons
now house of the dragons showrunner said
we will only see 9 of these in the very
first season since we're going to be
meeting so many new dragons i thought i
should make this video right before the
season begins not only will this give
you a good idea of who each of these
dragons are but i think everyone should
also know who is riding them during the
dance of the dragons since i am making
the video before house of the dragon
airs its first episode i do not have
official images for all of these dragons
i might end up showing an image of the
same dragon more than once now as far as
we know the valyrians were the first
ones who mastered the art of raising
dragons and they used them as their
weapons of war to establish their own
massive empire the valyrian freehold
after the doom of valyria however the
only dragons known to have survived were
five dragons on dragonstone those five
dragons belonged to house targaryen who
had brought them from valyria when they
went into exile now four of those
dragons eventually died on dragonstone
leaving only balerion the black dread
however the other dragons left eggs
behind and from those eggs hatched the
dragons veigar and maraxis and with
these three dragons aegon and his
sisters would bring the seven kingdoms
to their knees over the course of 150
years the targaryens rode their dragons
as a symbol of their power and as a
means of transport this will be on full
display in house of the dragon
now unfortunately we most likely will
not see valeria on the black dread while
he was alive from everything we've seen
in the teaser trailer so far it looks
like we will only see his massive skull
inside the red keep of king's landing
the last rider of belarion was viserys
targaryen in 93 ac
by then belarion was already hundreds of
years old after viserys mounted him they
flew around king's landing although
viserys later confided to his father
that he had originally intended to fly
belarion to dragonstone however fearing
the dragon lacked the strength to do so
viserys had opted otherwise belarion
later died in the year of 94 ac decades
before the start of the dance of the
dragons viserys targaryen would never
mount another dragon again
after belarion died vegar became the
last of the three targaryen dragons who
had fought in the conquest this also
left vegar as the largest living dragon
and when the dance of the dragons begins
she is nearly balerion's size
vegar was the hardened survivor of a
hundred battles and it's said that no
living dragon could match her size or
ferocity now as far as we know veigar is
bronze with greenish blue highlights and
bright green eyes one of her known
riders was lady laina velaryon daughter
of lord corliss velaryon and rhaenys
targaryen unfortunately lady lena will
die very early on in house of the dragon
and following lena's funeral on
driftmark aemond one eye targaryen will
mount veigar as his own dragon during
the run of house of the dragon we will
see emond and vegar fight in a number of
incredible battles against different
dragons vermathor who is a fearsome
beast is also known as the bronze fury a
male dragon once ridden by king jiharis
targaryen vermathor became riderless
when jiharis died in 103ac
now throughout the reign of viserys
targaryen vermathor had no new rider he
would remain on the island of
dragonstone where he would make his lair
in one of the smoking caverns of the
dragon mont and this is where he would
stay until after the start of the dance
of the dragons eventually it was decided
that rhaenyra would need more dragon
riders if she were to win back the iron
throne from alicent and her son aegon
now there were many men who attempted to
mount vermathor but the only one he
would bend his neck for was a
blacksmith's bastard who went by the
name of hugh hammer we will see hugh
hammer ride vermithor into battle during
house of the dragon
silverwing is a silvery she-dragon of
house targaryen she was ridden by queen
alisain targaryen the wife of the old
king jaehaerys now silver wing was
considered somewhat docile and friendly
to strangers after the death of alisaine
silverwing also went back to dragonstone
where she would make her lair in one of
the smoking caverns of the dragon mont
alongside vermathor this is also another
dragon that would eventually need
another rider once it was decided that
rhaenyra would need more dragons on her
side ultimately silverwing accepted a
dragonseed man in arms known as ulf the
white as our new writer
we will also see him ride silverwang
into battle during the dance of the
dragons
now dreamfire is a slender she dragon
who is mostly blue but also has some
silvery accents
this dragon was born during the reign of
aegon the conqueror
in the year of 35 ac long before the
dance of the dragons a young reina
targaryen mounted her now what's
interesting about dream fire is in the
year of 54 ac reina's best friend elisa
farman had stolen three of her dragon
eggs from dragonstone's hatcheries
before fleeing over to essos there are
many a song of ice and fire fans who
believe these three dragon eggs are the
ones who ended up with daenerys
targaryen so these three dragon eggs
very well could have been drogon
viserion and rhaegal now after reina
died in 73 ac dream fire made her lair
in the dragon pit of king's landing
during the reign of viserys targaryen
dreamfire would eventually bond with his
and alison's daughter helena targaryen
this is who we will most likely see
flying on dream fire in house of the
dragon melees has scarlet scales on her
wings for which she received her alias
the red queen
her crest and horns were brightest
copper in 75 ac melees was considered to
be one of the swiftest dragons in
westeros easily outflying caraxes and
veigar however at the start of the dance
of the dragons melees was said to have
grown lazy but was still fearsome when
she needed to be
in the year of 87 ac melees was mounted
by rhaenys targaryen wife of lord
corliss velaryon we will definitely see
rhaenys fly melees into battle during
the dance of the dragons in fact we will
see her fight more than one dragon and
one hell of a battle in the sky
karaxis also known as the blood worm is
written by the one and only daemon
targaryen as you've already seen in all
of the official photos and videos this
dragon is red big and lean
in battle he is formidable fearsome and
very experienced during the dance of the
dragons corax ceases about half the size
of the massive veigar we will see daemon
use this dragon in battle during the war
for the stepstones in the very first
season of house of the dragon by the end
of house of the dragon however we will
see daemon and karaxi's fight and one of
the most incredible dragon battles
george rr martin has ever written
now cyrax is a she dragon who is ridden
solely by rhaenyra targaryen she named
her dragon after a goddess of valyria
like we've already seen in many of the
official photos and videos cyrax has
gold and yellow dragon scales
she's also very big and formidable
though maybe not as fierce as daemon's
dragon rhaenyra was able to mount this
dragon at the very young age of 7 years
old making it very obvious that rhaenyra
was eager to fully embrace and harness
her own dragon blood we will see them on
full display all throughout this first
season of house of the dragon
now that i've shown you some of the
oldest and largest living dragons during
the dance of the dragons let me show you
some of the younger ones who are still
large enough to be ridden
sea smoke is a silver grey dragon who is
a fighting size during the dance but
still a young dragon and nimbler in the
air than his older brothers sea smoke is
a dragon written at first by sir lanor
velaryon the son of lorcorlus velaryon
and rhaenys targaryen and later written
by the dragon seed adam of hall this is
another dragon who would make its lair
on dragonstone after the death of its
rider it would remain there for nearly a
decade until they would eventually need
to find it another rider like the other
dragons living on dragonstone most of
those who would attempt to mount them
would die before even forming a bond
in fact this dragon sea smoke would even
kill wanna rhaenyra targaryen's queen's
guard before letting someone mount it
again
later the 15 year old adam of hall was
able to ride sea smoke however we will
see them enter the dance of the dragons
with fire and blood now sunfire has
gleaming golden scales that shine like
gold in the sunlight even his dragon
flame is golden as well
sun fire also known as sunfire the
golden is written by the future king
aegon the second of his name now based
on what archmaester gildane has said
sunfire is the most gorgeous dragon ever
seen in the known realm
big and heavy the splendid sunfire was a
formidable fighter despite his young age
we will see aegon fly this dragon into
battle in fact we should see them fight
in one of the most epic dragon battles
in house of the dragon if we do see what
happened in fire and blood i can
guarantee it will not let you down
tasarion also known as the blue queen is
a she dragon although her wings are dark
blue the scales on her belly are that of
bright beaten copper what's really
interesting about this dragon is her
flames are blue as well
by the start of the dance of the dragons
tessarion is a fighting size although
she is the youngest dragon of fighting
weight for the sight of king aegon
targaryen the second of his name we will
see this dragon bond with daron
targaryen the youngest son of viserys
targaryen and allison hightower they
should be seen in some of the fighting
as well
now vermax is a dragon ridden by
jacary's velaryon son of rhaenyra
targaryen there isn't a whole lot
written about this dragon but one thing
we do know is it was thriving and
growing larger every year it's also said
that vermax would get angry if it was
ever near the ice or snow
now when the dance of the dragons begins
varmax is large enough for jacarys to
fly we will see him fly into battle but
one thing i will say is this might not
be the dragon you want to fall in love
with arax is another dragon we don't
know that much about it is said that
this dragon might be white with yellow
flame with golden eyes and a golden
chest at the beginning of the dance
iraq's was mature enough to be ridden
although he was very young and still
growing this dragon will be mounted by
lucari's velaryon another one of
rhaenyra's sons and i will say this
lucaries will be its only rider now
taraxis is another dragon who was
thriving and growing every year
by the dance of the dragons he had
recently been able to fly long distances
with its rider joffrey velaryon but he
was not big enough for battle yet
this dragon will ultimately die during
the sacking of the dragon pit in king's
landing alright now the rest of these
dragons are hatchlings who were not big
enough to ride at the beginning of the
dance of the dragons
moondancer is the slender green she
dragon who will be ridden by the young
bela targaryen daughter of daemon
targaryen when the dance begun
moondancer was not large enough yet to
hold the 13 year old bela but she was
able to mount her only a year later now
it's said that when she mounted
moondancer the dragon was no larger than
a war horse and weighed even less
stormcloud was a young male dragon who
bonded with aegon the younger the son of
daemon and rhaenyra targaryen this
dragon should not be seen fighting in
the dance of the dragons
morgul was a young dragon bound to but
never ridden by jahira targaryen this
dragon dies before ever being ridden and
the dragon schreichross was a young
she-dragon bound to jiharis targaryen
during the dance of the dragons now this
jiharis targaryen is the son of king
aegon the second of his name it's not
the old king jiharis who you might be
thinking of schreikos is another dragon
who was never ridden during the dance
as you can see there are a lot of
dragons who are still alive during the
dance of the dragons and according to
george rr martin and house of the dragon
showrunners we should see 17 of these
dragons in the show nine of them will be
in the very first season in a recent
interview miguel sapochnick said we will
start to see the wild dragons on
dragonstone in the second season
assuming that it does get the green
light from hbo now those three wild
dragons living on dragonstone are grey
ghosts sheepsteeler and the cannibal
since i did make this video before house
of the dragon's first episode aired some
of the names you heard in the video
might be different in the show some of
the characters who rode the dragons
might be different in the show as well
everything i said in this video is based
on what it says in a song of ice and
fire and fire and blood
now this is what really will separate
house of the dragon from game of thrones
with this many living and fighting
dragons in westeros at the same time we
will finally see house targaryen at the
height of their power unlike game of
thrones where we only saw three living
dragons house of the dragons is set
during a time when the dragons reign
from the sky
i wanna know which dragons you're
excited to see the most for me i would
have to say it's vegar the incredible
beast who is a veteran of over 100
battles i know i cannot wait to see him
dance over the god's eye so leave me
your thoughts down below i want to know
what dragon you like the most
also make sure you subscribe now so you
can be the first to know whenever i
release all of my new videos during the
season i will be making several videos
every week during the whole season i
hope i'll see all of you here for those
as well as always i want to thank
everyone for watching this video have a
great day everyone i'll see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you